what attracted you to choose such a very
diverse cast of great actors well you
know Jurassic Park is not is not an
American film it's a film that belongs
to the whole world and I thought it was
very important that when we reintroduced
this film that we have people that that
represent the whole world and so we not
just the actors on the stage mr. Pratt
and Miss Howard and the great Omar see
but you're fond Khan and BD Wong and and
Vincent D'Onofrio Judy Greer and Nick
Robinson ty simpkins this whole cast
everybody has a moment you know
everybody gets to be a true character
and have an identity and I think we
really get to see into the souls of all
these people a kiss girl Quizzle people
image I see back probably what I
considered don't take it right it's um
you know I think what was most important
to me was was to not be derivative and
to not just make a carbon copy of a
movie that I loved I think that's kind
of the third rail of anyone in my
generation because we love those movies
so much
and so I tried to just recreate a
feeling and I hope that when people
watch it they they can have the same
experience as I did with the first film
I was 16 when I saw it and I regret back
to being a child and my goal would be
for for everyone in the audience to
watch the movie as you know 8 to 12 year
olds regardless of their age do you
remember how you felt when you first saw
Jurassic Park shell-shocked basically um
and and and something else that that
that was a was was huge for me when I
when I saw that movie was that I I was
12 years old and my parents were very
strict and they would never let me see a
movie as scary as Jurassic Park was at
that time at that age and and yet they
went on opening night and and
they they came home i distinctively
remember this because all my friends
were going to see the movie on that
Friday and um and I wasn't allowed to go
and and I was devastated and and they
came home and and and they said you know
this is Bryce this is cinema history you
must see this movie in the theater -
Chris so what do you recall of that
first experience it was good thanks good
well dinosaurs that was a see this is
really a to even be an actor for a
living is very much a dream let alone to
be given an opportunity to be
instrumental in continuing to tell the
story of you know a franchise a legacy
that was really very important to you as
a kid I was 13 when I saw in the
theaters I'll never forget it I it's my
first big event movie the idea that we
get to be part of making this movie is
is a huge honor and the fact that the
movie is really good as a giant relief
Omar Khayyam combivir Doris Wilma Lucien
Calloway commander Pott ECT sister
acquired visual Muskaan özkan özkan
advocacy team secured a more historic
token surprise phenom plenty de Becque
to evict us Cossack important Nativity
small Oh flip a visual magnetic blue
favor Detroit avec OC beaucoup de mo doc
waste of a participant melody new makan
Tok adolescence avec accredited real
surely tornado simulator Faro de
participate about your city take action
except exceptionally say normal for you
I mean running around in high heels for
you running next to these creatures that
must have been also something right
sometimes when you play a character
there's there's an element of the
characters costume or you know an object
that they have that they kind of
represents that the sort of the the
metaphor of who that character is in the
world and
and for me the Claire was her high heels
she she starts the film buttoned up
sterile she's an individual who has in
in the the quest for for profit has
compromised her own humanity and during
as the story evolves so does she and she
goes out into the jungle and her white
clothes get muddy and um and ripped up
and she gets bruised and she's filthy
and she's sweaty but girlfriend does not
take off her heels did you feel that
these dinosaurs also represent the
animal part of us one of the nice things
about this movie is is the human
relationships that exist and I think
that's really important for any story
you can have spectacular dinosaurs all
around you but I think it's the human
story that makes that it really drew me
into this movie and and part of that
human story is my character Owen trying
to draw the animal out of a Claire you
know she's I want it you know and at
some point the whole situation does draw
the animal out of her and she goes down
to that that fight-or-flight mentality
and and well if you've seen the film you
know she does something very heroic and
send animalistic and incredibly sexy and
that leads to this kind of Awesome and
unexpected romantic moment between uh
Owen and Claire's so it's nice that you
know he is my own as a very much a
respect for the natural order of things
and where he fits in the food chain and
he sees us all as just animals and
Claire's a little more reserved and so
he likes and when she turns into an
animal
you